five years is a long time to spend
developing a game and in even longer
time in being able to keep any game much
less a new god of war title under wraps
but that's what the folks over at Santa
Monica studios have done the iconic God
of War has been reimagined for the
current PlayStation generation after
spending over 50 hours in this
gorgeously realizing world criticized
return on April 20th is nothing short of
divine
nothing can be more jarring than having
cradles becoming a father to a young
child at Reyes clear as play a set off
on the journey to the highest peak in
the land to spread the ashes of a wife
and a mother the path becomes one of
enlightenment of Kratos being a father
and a tree is learning about being a god
it is an intricately woven tail when
Kratos has passed showing its subtle
influences in his struggle to be a good
father to the young lady suffice to say
there are several pivotal moments that
see the pair clash grow and ultimately
become a team that isn't all to be
reckoned
the wonderful facial animations of the
main cuffs thus wonders at molting and
conveying the gravity of the situation
and find themselves any and now with a
camera that never ever cut away this
itself is a technical and design marvel
to say the least but now players can and
will always feel the emotional stakes of
what is presented in front of them for
the first time in a long time the plot
of God of War becomes an enticing
feature rather than be a truer a string
of events the link or the action
god award does an admirable job of
building a believable world tent with
little twist that fits in the cradle
says appearance in this new world and
how these celestial beings react to an
intruder of some renown the many vistas
the duo visit absorb it order and comes
to light with every rustling and
billowing wind got a wall ramp perfectly
on the PlayStation 4 Pro without so much
as a star while displaying a crisp frame
rate beautiful colors and visuals like a
painting come to life
to combat and puzzles the Leviathan acts
grunts Kratos the ability to please
enemies with its Faust properties and
can be thrown and retrieved a will and a
tray is played an important role in
harasser as well as standing combos
keeping enemies controller
our
Kratos would not be the God of War the
tops and they are friendly excuse to be
unlocked or which ends near the ministry
reaction be bandit with a shoe with an
advisor and even during his Spartan
range there plenty of customizations to
jump into for the perfect combat flow
and yes Atria's gets his own specific
skill tree as well all these skills can
be further augmented by crafting
equipment but first for the 13 euro
series good in the Wow can never be
compared to gear that is crafted by the
hilarious doorman brothers but
considering two of many characters
players across paths with the best gear
sets require have to find the two years
and will often point you to option a
challenging side quest that accounts for
some of God awards best moments
the enemy's range of human height Rogers
to fearsome trolls and August and when
you turn some nightmarish creatures from
hell it all combines at campaigning for
Kratos increased
a great variety of enemies we feel ready
Austin combat at Ottawa even better and
they require cunning a strategy to
overconfidence of the time
the several boss fights are the best
parts of the action as over the top set
pieces and bloody brutal savage II they
hearkened to the golf s of all returned
and more major america emphasizes the
true power traders and train without
being over and out
if you're looking for a game that shows
off various systems working perfectly
intended this is it
the Sun is also integral to puzzles
which the Leviathan oxygen absorber it's
freezing ability the trails ability to
read and translate runes not only adds
to the mythos surrounding God of War but
it's also important in unlocking parts
of the world his small stature also
works well in circumventing obstacles
and is a truly indispensable airline
what makes got a wall a truly wonderful
experience is how everything comes into
play perfectly an intriguing tale seemed
to an engaging and growing relationship
between a father and son this is an epic
adventure troost Alex three distinct
level designs truly impressive all while
giving players the freedom to achieve
visceral and satisfying combat
it has been a long time coming a
creative director Cory below and the
team over at Santa Monica Studios have
indeed outdone themselves in delivering
a true epic that is the crown jewel of
the color war franchise
and if you're part of the PlayStation
family there's simply no reason to not
pick up this gem of a game and became
one of the greatest journeys in gaming
you